um if you haven't already sorry i didn't
anticipate this
but if you have drawn any of your graphs
your axes across the page
can i recommend again to doing that the
whole point of this exercise is i mean
you know what these look like
but i want to make some comparisons
against displacement velocity
acceleration across time it's gonna be
super useful to be able to say
look here is one instance in time and i
can tell you about all three of these
quantities
just by looking at what they're equal to
vertically okay so
if you haven't already getting down the
page i'll give you another minute or so
now it will help you to have a ruler
with you
as we go through this okay because as i
said the point is not
can you graph these that's kind of a
foregone conclusion
i assume you can graph these maybe that
was a wrong assumption to me
the real thing that i'm looking for is
can we draw
some conclusions about motion
by looking at these graphs and a ruler
will help you compare displacement
velocity and acceleration
all at the same time assuming
you have a reasonably consistent time
axis
okay so for starters let's just think
about displacement okay
what's this thing doing it's going
up and then down and then up and
down or right
and then left and then right and then
left
we could have changed all that obviously
if we had changed the phase
right um but that's what it's doing and
that's fairly simple we get that
okay good let's move down and see if we
can draw some conclusions and see what's
going on
okay for instance when you've got
where's my
that's weird okay when you've got
something
like this on this graph we call that
a stationary point what does that
correspond to
well it corresponds to the fact that
your velocity
is zero of course it does right i mean
if we were thinking about this
in y and x and d y and the x terms the
way you find a stationary point is by
saying d y and d x equals zero
but instead what i'm saying here is look
when i've
stopped moving okay when the
displacement is not changing what that
means is
that there's another one okay that means
velocity is zero
cool that makes sense what else can we
see
tell me where is the particle moving
fastest
the particles may be fastest at these
extremities
right because what does this represent
for instance this moment in time
right t equals zero this means that i am
moving in which direction
let's go let's let's keep it in up down
because that will be less confusing
which direction am i moving
this is the velocity graph this is the
velocity graph
and this is displacement so when i look
at velocity and i see that velocity is
well
for this graph velocity is one
it's positive one so which direction am
i going in
i'm going up of course i'm going up look
see there i am
okay so does that make sense now
as it goes down here what's going on
velocity is going from one
to zero it's at zero now what does that
correspond to
i'm slowing down i'm still going in that
direction i haven't turned around yet
but i'm slowing down until eventually
i reach a stop cool that makes sense
all right but what happens it continues
it turns around
this is a turning point which
corresponds to a change in sign for the
velocity
right like it literally turns around
okay so that's why it becomes negative
over here
and what's how would you describe the
speed speed
as i go from this point to well that's
what's that
that's pi on two isn't it pi on two to
pi what's happening to the speed
the speed is increasing you gotta be
careful about how you talk about this
would you say the velocity is decreasing
you probably could but it's a bit tricky
the word decreasing
is kind of like the word decelerating
right the way we use it we tend to mean
it's getting smaller
well it's getting more negative that's a
better way to say it it's less ambiguous
okay so i am moving faster and faster in
the downward direction until i get to
here
right this is the fastest point at which
i'm moving down with
and it corresponds to this point
ah so what does that mean at these
points here
one two three four
five what do you say about the velocity
at those points
that's where you have the greatest
velocity right which corresponds to of
course the displacement graph
being steepest hmm
have we squeezed everything out of
velocity graph that's interesting is
there anything else that you notice
looks okay to me let's move on to
acceleration
what do we see from this guy okay well
again let's start at the origin
start the origin here i am time zero
okay what acceleration
is the particle object whatever what
acceleration is it
experiencing at time zero it's not
experiencing
any acceleration
but the second i move off that the
moment i move off right
after time equals zero what is the first
acceleration the particle experiences
it's acceleration in the downward
direction
does that make sense yeah it does
i'm i am moving up but i'm moving up at
a slower rate because something's
pushing me down this way
it's pushing me down so hard eventually
i stop right
now have a look at that point where i
stop um what time is that
it has a value what time it's pi on two
okay so at that point i'm at the
extremity of motion
at that same point i have velocity zero
what's my acceleration at that point at
that time i should say
that's this point here
so what would you say about the
acceleration
this is the strongest the acceleration
gets isn't it that's the most
negative it gets right so the further
away i am from my center of motion the
harder i'm being pushed
back to the center of version which of
course is why he always comes back
right you can see if i go along to
what's this time three pi on two
right when i go to three pi on two in
the same way
my velocity is zero and here
again the acceleration is at its
strongest in the other direction
upwards i mean push back toward the
center of motion okay
in fact i'm always being pushed toward
the center of motion can you see that
have a look watch with me
right because this graph is sine t and
this is negative sine t
right if this guy is in the positive
direction
i'm being pushed in the negative
direction can you see that you see that
corresponding
if i'm in the negative direction i mean
pushed in the positive direction
of course he has to be because if he was
in the positive direction and he was
being pushed in the positive direction
he'd never come back he'd just go wee
and off he goes
right see you later guys not simple
harmonic motion
okay now
get into acceleration acceleration is
really where all the interesting stuff
happens okay
because of what we've been saying if
you're positive somewhere right
then your acceleration is negative and
vice versa
but not only that the more positive your
displacement
is the more negative your acceleration
is
right so in fact i could say
rather than say acceleration is a
function of time
acceleration as a function of time
clearly i should be able to say i could
reword acceleration
as a function of displacement namely
depending on where you are you are being
accelerated in a certain
way namely the other way right the more
positive you are
the more negative you're being
accelerated the more negative you are
the more positively you're accelerated
now look at this we just reason through
it by looking at what this all means but
you already saw it i bet when we develop
these equations by differentiating right
of course you can see what x double dot
is in terms of x
because look there's x well i should say
there's x right let me rewrite it for
you come back to your time equations
all right if i put that n squared out
the front
maybe i should take that negative as
well what i'm left with is a
sine nt plus alpha
that's x so i should be able to write
this
does that make sense what's this saying
the further you are in a positive
direction well your acceleration will be
negative
that you'll be directly proportional
that's what this n is just a constant
remember
okay now just be careful i know we wrote
it in the same spot because that's you
can see the progression
right ah but this last line that i've
just written this guy
he's not a time equation anymore right
we have a name for this we introduced it
under exponential growth and decay
it's a an equation that relates
a function to one of its derivatives
which we get by differentiation right
remember what it's called
it's called a differential equation
this is not a time equation because look
there's there's no time in there right
he doesn't this doesn't care when it's
happening
all it cares about is where it's
happening so this is the differential
equation
this is the differential equation for
simple harmonic motion
are there any questions at this point
how's your brain doing is it okay
do i need to play the doctor who theme
again to get you
okay now i will finish off before i get
you to go with these questions by saying
one last thing
okay um we looked at these equations we
said okay it's got to be sine
cos right um can you see by the way i
could just as easily have started with a
cos
nt plus alpha watch what happens
x equals a cos nt plus alpha
tell me what's x dot
negative a sine n
sorry t plus alpha yeah
what's x double dot
negative a another n
cause look
x double dot is still minus n squared
x can you see it like it's still there
right
um you will notice there's a different
relationship between x and x dot here
as there is here i introduce the
negative here right which is why when
you get differential equations for
simple harmonic motion
they sort of conveniently leave out x
dot
the real relationship is between not
displacement velocity
but displacement and acceleration that's
where the real relationship is
so i could just as easily start it from
cos and then from sine why would you do
that by the way
why would you start with why would you
choose this is your equation
rather than that as your equation why
might you favor one over the other
the the difference between these cos and
sign is just
phase that's the only difference right
so really you would want this
if you don't want to start at the center
of motion
if you want to start you know what close
looks like right if you want to start an
extremity of motion
you'll choose cause okay